m
[Musique]
inauguré en 1875 l'opéra de paris se
dresse au centre de la ville son
architecture puissante du à garnier et
bien dans le style napoléon iii qui fait
alors fureur dans la capitale le palais
du chant et de la danse et décoré par
paul baudry et les statuts sont de
carpeaux monsieur l'administrateur
qu'est ce que c'est que diriger l'opéra
dirigé l'opéra c'est ne jamais oublier
que le coeur de la maison bas sur la
scène c'est ne jamais oublier non plus
ce qui se passe sous la seine au dessus
de la scène derrière la scène ce qui se
passe dans les studios de répétition ce
qui se passe dans les bureaux de
l'administration et ce qui se passe dans
les ateliers de construction
depuis quand existe l'opéra l'opéra
existe sous la forme d' académie royale
de musique depuis 16 169 c'est donc
louis xiv qui avait fondé l'académie
royale de musique devenue de nos jours
académie nationale de musique vous
décrire le palais garnier
tout le monde le connaît mais je pense
que peu de gens soupçonnent l'immensité
intérieur de ce bâtiment
vous savez que il a à 14 m de plus de
hauteur que notre dame de paris
vous avez qu' il ne tiendrait pas dans
la cour carrée du louvre et vous savez
également que la comédie française toute
entière tiendrait en revanche sur la
scène et les coulisses dans le volume
occupé par la scène et les coulisses
combien de personnes travaillent dans ce
monde
on peut dire que il y à un millier de
personnes qui travaillent d'une façon
permanente je ne parle pas des artistes
qui passent ou même des techniciens qui
passe dans cette maison mais de ceux qui
restent on peut évaluer à un millier de
personnes tant artistes que technicien
que constructeur et qu'administratif
[Musique]
claude bessy directrice de l'école de
danse de l'opéra n'est ce pas une charge
un peu trop lourde pour une jeune femme
c'est pas une charge trop lourde parce
que si vous voulez la connaissance de
notre métier nous l'avons relativement
jeune puisque nous commençons très tôt
quand j'ai commencé la danse à 10 ans
donc il se trouve que maintenant je suis
capable si vous voulez de conseillers
d'enseignés de pouvoir guider des
enfants arrivés encore tout jeune femme
quand vous dites qu'est ce que l'école
de danse de l'opéra et à l'école de
danse de l'opéra c'est une école c'est
l'apprentissage d'un métier parce que
c'est une école si vous voulez qu'ils
préparent à une carrière c'est pas on ne
prend pas ici des enfants qui n'ont pas
l'intention je ne dis pas qu'ils vont
tous réussir mais qui n'ont pas tous
l'intention de devenir un jour danseurs
n'ont pas seulement danseur étoile mes
danseurs de corps de ballet du
chorégraphe ou des professeurs plus tard
alors c'est une école très difficile
parce que l on toute la scolarité
normale à faire puisqu'elle passent leur
baccalauréat et quand le bepc et est
obligatoire pour leur engagement mais
qu'elles peuvent continuer donc jusqu'au
baccalauréat si elles veulent elles
doivent donc faire toutes leurs études
toute leur scolarité comme les enfants
ordinaires plus tout le travail de danse
qui demande évidemment
un entraînement physique et une
résistance importante puisqu'elles ont
aussi des spectacles afférents plus que
combien d'heures de danse la plus grande
par jour elles ont une heure et demie de
danse par jour non c'est parce qu
insuffisant si vous l'aimez vraiment
elles ne peuvent pas faire plus avec
tout le programme de scolarité qui lie à
faire enlever les cols durs combien
d'années en moyenne six ans entre 6 et 8
ans et combien avez-vous d'élèves
actuellement nous avons 115 élèves
garçons et filles nous allons garçons et
filles mais nous avons une petite
proportion de garçons en rapport des
filles nous avons
28 garçons pour 86 et puis quelqu'un
fille
pour moi expliquer pourquoi bien c'est
très difficilement explicable parce que
c'est une carrière qui est très ouverte
pour les hommes il ya peu d'hommes dans
le monde entier pas seulement en france
en tant que danseur les bons danseurs
sont très rares et
bien je ne sais pas c'est un métier qui
n'est pas encore très connue des parents
je pense que pour les garçons aussi ils
viennent plus tard à la danse que les
filets petite fille de dix ans je sais
beaucoup plus féminin à leur demande
plutôt à leurs parents de devenir
danseuse et pour les garçons on en a qui
viennent très souvent parce que la soeur
a commencé à faire de la danse parce que
des amis l'ont entraînée à une leçon de
danse mais en général si vous voulez ça
commence toujours plus tard pour les
garder c'est pourquoi maintenant nous
allons ouvrir la porte aux garçons un
petit peu plus tard
[Musique]
e
votre nouveau poste vous permet-il de
danse et encore oui bien sûr vous savez
les l'école en ce qui me concerne la
direction artistique et le guider les
enfants je m'en occupe
le matin de 8h30 à 12h et puis à partir
de 1h je consacre les après midi à mes
soirées
si vous voulez en ce qui concerne mon
travail de danseuses et deux paragraphes
puisque je fais aussi pas mal des
paragraphes i pour l'extérieur
[Musique]
l'opéra est né en italie au xvème siècle
en toscane exactement mais c'étaient des
représentations sacrées dans lesquels on
intercale et des chansons des coeurs et
des danses ce n'est qu'au xviie siècle
que le véritable opéra tel que nous le
connaissons aujourd'hui voit le jour à
florence c'est le forfait de monteverdi
en france c'est lully qu'est le
véritable créateur de l'opéra que l'on
appelle à la cour une tragédie lyrique
puis rameaux au milieu du xviiie siècle
créé l'opéra ballet dans les annes
galante
il atteindra la perfection du genre ce
n'est qu'au 19e siècle connaît le style
grand opéra avec rossini donizetti en
italie en france
à lévis et meyer baer en allemagne
rennaise il introduit la puissance avec
d'énormes orchestres et des coeurs
gigantesques suivi en france par berlioz
gounod chabrier saint saëns réagissent
contre les excès du romantisme
enfin le xxème siècle voit apparaître le
renouveau de l'opéra français avec
debussy et fauré qui ouvre la voie à
l'opéra impressionniste de prokofiev
darius milhaud et au niger l'avenir de
l'opéra je le vois avec un grand
optimisme parce que au cours de la
dernière décade ou même peut-être des 20
dernières années
c'était à qui crierait que l'opéra était
mort que l'opéra se mourait que ça
n'intéressait plus personne que les
jeunes s'en détachaient or je constate
que nous avons de plus en plus de monde
l'opéra actuellement est plein tous les
jours à chaque représentation
et beaucoup de jeunes viennent vous
savez que dans chaque série nous avons
ménagé une représentation réservée aux
comités d'entreprise que ces
représentations sont très suivies et que
donc le public de l'opéra au lieu de
comme on le pensait de se scléroser de
restreindre est en train de se dilater
[Musique]
les grandes soirées de l'opéra attire
encore le tout paris qui se pressent
dans une ambiance de luxe un peu suranné
[Musique]
le superbe escalier à double révolution
voit passer tous les grands noms des
arts des lettres et de la politique
au milieu d'une double haie de gardes
républicains en grande tenue
mais ce ne sont là que des exceptions et
l'opéra de paris s'enorgueillit d'offrir
à des prix raisonnables des sièges pour
tout ce qui est encore aujourd'hui la
rive
[Musique]